l'île d'anticosti semble être à la
croisée des eaux de placement à l'unesco
lui permettra de tourner la page du
pétrole peut-être est de mise et en lieu
et place sur l'autre courant celui du
tourisme le maire john pinault a quitté
d'ailleurs sont ils au coeur de l'hiver
pour livrer son plaidoyer directement à
morial chercher des appuis donc pour
forcer entre autres la province a brisé
son silence à se ranger dans le camp
d'une candidature de l'île d'anticosti
au détriment peut-être de celle du pont
plus que centenaire de la ville de
québec pour la postérité et positionner
le décréter l'autoroute a1 devraient
être les le toujours vécu là je pêche
tourisme mais villégiature je pense que
c'est vraiment faire vos créations et
pour moi c'est un endroit absolument
merveilleux que je voudrais pas que je
vais les générations futures
mais derrière cette candidature de l'île
paradisiaque aux paysages sauvages se
dresse très pesant l'éléphant du pétrole
cela explique-t-il le mutisme du
gouvernement québécois dans cette
affaire l'absence d'appui alors qu'il ne
reste plus que quelques jours pour
présenter à ottawa le choix du québec au
concours de beauté du l'unesco le forage
sur l'île est au plan politique une
bombe incendiaire depuis 2014
cette année là le gouvernement du parti
québécois de pauline marois avait
autorisé le forage en 2015 le
gouvernement libéral de philippe
couillard avait semblé renverser la
vapeur jamais le délabrement de l'île
d'anticosti n'apportera ma signature
en 2016 le gouvernement renversé sa
propre vapeur et engage à lille en avant
tout en autorisant aux besoins le forage
de centaines de puits à la recherche du
fameux pétrole on ne connaît pas non
plus les produits toxiques qui vont être
identifiées pour la fracturation
on veut savoir comment voter en surface
ces produits taxés luc noël et préfet
d'une municipalité régionale de comté
comme les appelle au québec dont une
région celle de la main gagny où se
trouve l'île d'anticosti second solo
c'est que par puis ça ferait entre 15 et
20 millions de litres d'eau il n'y a pas
assez d'eau dans les rues des dates
costi pourquoi la fracturation
c'est comme si un médecin opérée à coeur
ouvert sans connaître le groupe sanguin
son passé
québec a autorisé par exemple l'an
dernier le prélèvement de plus de 30
millions de litres d'eau dans les
rivières d'anticosti pour alimenter
trois forages exploratoires pour
lesquels le feu vert a été accordée par
le ministère de l'environnement on
aurait respecté toutes les règles nous
il n'y a aucun engagement pour faire de
l'exploitation nous le contrat qu'on
doit respecter c'est un contrat pour
l'exploration seulement des
préoccupations importantes c'est que
anticosti une population de ce monde qui
est en voie de disparition
techniquement aux yeux des comités
scientifiques d'environnement canada
sylvain archambault et biologiste à la
société pour la nature et les parcs du
canada
cette population doit est en déclin et
les rivières des débits sont extrêmement
faibles des rivières qu'on peut presque
traverser à pied dont les sortir et
d'autorisation pour permettre de près de
15% du débit de ces rivières dans quelle
mesure ça va affecter le niveau d'eau
dans quelle mesure ça va isoler d'aider
certains saumons dans des sacs un
secteur affecté des alevins sont en
train de se nourrir c'est un tas de
questions qu'on se pose
les trois partis politiques principaux
s'entendent sur le fait que ce serait
une bonne chose d'aller explorer et
exploiter le pétrole anticosti les
danois se sont posé ces questions lors
récemment les suédois l'ont fait ils se
sont donné ce qu'on pourrait appeler des
plans crédibles de sortie du pétrole
militant de la première heure contre
l'industrie des gaz de schiste au québec
le metteur en scène dominic champagne se
questionne lui aussi sur le bien fondé
de la décision du gouvernement québécois
d'exploiter le pétrole de schiste à
l'identique ostie on a un sérieux
problème avec la combustion des énergies
fossiles
sur cette terre où on est en train avec
nos émissions de carbone de remettre en
cause les conditions mêmes de la vie sur
terre
c'est un fait de l'autre côté on a la
classe politique canadienne québécoise
qui nous dit le pétrole et la voix de
notre prospérité et là on viendrait de
découvrir une sorte de pactole anticosti
mais tout à coup quand cette prospérité
la menace la qualité de l'eau qu'on boit
de l'air qu'on respire la terre d'où on
tire notre pitance on se pose des
questions sur la valeur de cette la
qualité de ce développement le canada
compte déjà dix lieux naturels inscrits
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco dont
les packs des montagnes rocheuses en
alberta et en colombie-britannique le
parc national du gros morne à terre
neuve et labrador le parc national de
miguasha en gaspésie donc au québec
ainsi que huit autres sites culturels
dont l'arrondissement historique du
vieux-québec le canal rideau à ottawa
tous des lieux qui attirent non pas les
pétrolières
mais les touristes un reportage de radio
canada international